we before the tournament we thought we'd
have play-offs in every round but so far
there's a leader yeah and okay king's
pawn opening
will we see the berlin defense it is the
berlin defense again and a repetition of
their first game so far um both players
utilizing the same opening nakamura
retreating his bishop and now magnus
creating a pin this isn't necessarily
the most popular move um i think
magnus's choice in the first game is
much more popular but this one does ask
nakamura some questions do you think
often magnus just trusts peter hannah to
just send me what i should play i think
he trusts him yeah absolutely
and i can tell you hikaru nakamura has
actually played
this variation before this exact one and
he's had great results um he defeated
ali reza ferrugia in 2020 and also lavon
ironian in 2020. move on
definitely previous results so okay
nakamura brought the black queen out and
now white's knight developing yeah
nakamura these days in longer games that
isn't necessarily what he's comfortable
with okay he does bring him he does play
okay so so which scenario is correct
it's a
magnus is indeed a preparation or b
magnus doesn't know that hikaru has
played this before that that's exactly
what was played by far the most logical
move okay i was going to say you
probably don't want to flick in this
this idea with white because now
there is a potential hook as we call it
if black's pawns on the right side push
forward they will definitely be able to
create an open line because white has
just pushed upon himself all right
that's being posted let's picture the
competition
perfect timing yes get back to the chest
because magnus he's decided to open up
the center and this is very ambitious
for the world champion this also makes a
lot of sense black's king remains in the
middle he hasn't committed yet and
usually while your opponent's king is in
the center a sitting duck a clear target
then you want to open things up
all of them i can tell you this was
studied in
the 20th of september 2021 so someone
has been looking out this line who was
it he was interesting was it magnus was
it hikaru was it one of their coaches
yeah who knows okay and incidentally
this rook move is the next move a court
studied according to my database a few
days ago on september 27th someone was
looking at pushing the pawn to attack
the bishop yeah this would have been
critical the acid test of white's idea
because once the bishop steps back later
in the game you will have opportunities
to push further forward and open up
lines he's about to push this pawn
forward we see it on his screen and
there we go
uh white has created this trio in the
center of the board with it makes
perfect sense especially because you
know now the king is on opposite sides
of the board it's war we're always
taught go forward open lines and uh yeah
magnus is driving to the beat and i just
love this move especially because hikaru
cannot capture that pawn it's not gonna
actually solve the issues long term okay
first he trades his bishop off for a
knight but what's the idea is he going
to grab a pawn hikara nakamura he's
distracted away the white knight is he
going to get greedy and take this pawn
that's up for grabs
he's played it he's done it because now
we should mention if white's pawn
captures the black pawn in the middle
okay wow actually what's happening here
because there's like the recaptures
then he's attacking the white bishop
yeah but you counter attack against the
black queen and
temporarily white is a piece up uh okay
we're going for this but now he is about
to win the night back
okay magnus frowning
this position is critical right now
white is a whole bishop up for just one
pawn but can he preserve his knight he's
got to worry about his knight and he's
got to worry about his queen he can't
save them both what will magnus do to
solve this issue and uh to kind of pluck
up the courage to go for so
okay he's about to move that white
knight oh he's found it oh my god i mean
that is this is that is impressive
why he's the world champion he's always
got his
his eyes open for these really
unexpected opportunities wow
and now this position as we mentioned
looking very good for white black is not
out of it it's level material but
white's queen is attacking a porn and
white's rooks are going to start
mobilizing and attacking the black queen
and king but
maybe okay he finds it we shouldn't
doubt nakamura he is super active he
needs to be
and
magnus seizing the opportunity to put a
rook on an open line and uh okay now we
have uh
i was gonna say no don't take it okay
surprising choice for magnus carlsen he
swaps the queens off and again breaking
the rules of david and ivanka
[Laughter]
maybe that's why we're not magnus's
carson's level
yeah we were surprised because black's
king is clearly the weaker of the two
look at the white rook opposite the
black king a clear target and normally
when you're attacking you want to keep
the queens on it looks like giri might
be about to win again and finish off
that match wow
some black pieces as well and each gear
is sitting behind magnus carlsen
and it could be over in that one if
geary wins game three with the black
pieces this one could also be over if
magnus wins with the white pieces
yeah so magnus maybe just with that uh
result in mind knowing that so is likely
to lose he has minimized the risk and
look at white's rook now a very strong
piece on that sixth rank deep in black's
camp attacking black's isolated pawn in
the middle black had to tie his own
brook down defending it and now i expect
to see magnus adopt a very typical
endgame strategy for him he's going to
put all his pawns on light squares to
complement his bishop on dart square
okay first he brings his bishop to the
center
i'm surprised by that one what happens
is now if black's king goes to attack
the white rook i thought white wanted to
use his own rook to back up okay he's
going to do this the two rooks stacking
up together and now white spawns are on
light squares look how paralyzed the two
black rooks are they can't do anything
so this is a good decision by hikaru
actually just to
step back with his knight but at the
same time it is like defensive mode
activated i mean there's nothing active
happening here in hikaru's position
maybe not even necessary yeah okay
magnus we know him he loves to push his
pawns forward especially these rooks
pawns the a and h pawns he's getting
ready for a race in the end game so uh
very logical to push pawns on the side
you're stronger and nakamura tries to
block things up he puts his pawns on
light squares before they get fixed on
dart squares as targets for white's
bishop and here comes the king white's
king
has a clear path in actually and there's
definitely no danger to it because the
queens have disappeared white's king
will happily march towards those black
pawns now on the right well i think we
should forget the evaluation bar i think
we should just focus on
the human assessment and the human
assessment is this is brilliant for
white and the white king now has a clear
path into the game and just
take a look at how paralyzed the black
knight is on this open line are much
better than blacks rooks
secondarily if you look at white's king
right now it's about to march in towards
the black pawns white's king is better
than the blacks king but most
importantly of all this knight is
completely stuck and every square it
wants to go to is controlled by this
bishop this is what we mean by the
knight being trapped in its stable the
white uh the black knight completely
dominated by white's bishop uh so okay
nakamura needs to do something and he
needs to do something fast so he brings
his rook to the second rank this isn't
actually threatening anything this pawn
for example is defended by white's
bishop but he's just tying down the
white king to the defense of this pawn
and that's why magnus tries to evict
this very strong rook and we see a rook
trade and nakamura stopping the white
king entering the position by cutting
off its entry squares this night i was
expecting this move actually because uh
the idea is to push the pawn forward one
square and then we'll get the rook to
dive into the c6 square can i even do to
be active no counter play just passive
that's depressing as well defending
defending defending and knowing that one
slip will immediately result in defeat
no chance of winning the game either for
nakamura only two results possible a
white win or a draw so okay he's decided
to wait with the black rock and there we
go it's been played
and he's just going for your plan your
anchor he's created a nice outpost for
the white rook a nice square for it to
use as a launch pad this okay we see a
trade of pawns but now white's rook is
threatening to come up to the c6 square
anchored by this pawn where it is going
to kind of switch its focus across to
the right and so but now this time the
knight can jump into this squad okay the
king
steps
steps back okay so magnus sorry hicaro
is really rolling up into a little ball
and just trying to wait
and uh okay magnus has created a pin the
black knight now fully fully stuck on
this square uh if it moves then the
black rook drops off to the white rook
magnus he's completely dominated that
black knight
and now what next do you think he is now
basically uh playing for the win in this
game not only the draw and you know yeah
yeah for sure
absolutely you know just uh take a look
at hikaru's pieces totally paralyzed
there's uh no active plan whatsoever and
maybe that will be magnus's strategy
black is tied down here we see nakamura
just moving his rook back and forth back
and forth waiting for magnus to show his
hand but for carlson if he does start to
create some threats he's going to hope
that nakamura gets lower and lower and
lower on the clock and then he might
pounce if anish loses this the magnus
carlton could be a win about to win the
match yeah and magnus chooses to
relocate the king
just to improve it by slowly moving it
up the board and
now hikaru actually develops his knight
so big moment here to capture the knight
or not if the white bishop captures that
black knight as it does the black king
has to recapture uh the black pawn if it
recaptured would have weakened the
seventh rank white's rook would have
delivered some deadly checks and here we
have a check
okay this allows the black king to step
forward okay does it want to though does
it want to allow the white rook into
that seventh rank no the answer is no no
and uh king steps backwards
okay nakamura he's defending this game
really nicely just like he did in the
last one he's clinging on surviving and
white's king trying to reactivate itself
it took a step back because it had to at
some point but now it's heading back
towards uh more active squares and now
okay nakamura
he's trying to use the black rook now
this is the best the black rook's ever
been but uh this is the second plan in
action the white king is now finally
within uh touching distance of those
pawns on the right okay so black's rook
as predicted has tried to activate it's
now on the second rank buying up one of
white's pawns yeah it would be a little
bit too ambitious i was i was thinking
step up
two squares
yup this makes some sense
this is the side white stronger after
all and now nakamura he's trying to pin
down the white king he's trying to stop
the white king from advancing because
now if the white king moves black's rook
on this third rank will capture what
else could he do or defend as
defend the pawn and just say hey
i uh i release the king from this
defensive duties you are now free to
attack okay he defends this pawn so
black's king coming across and now white
king look how active it is going after
these black pawns black is defending but
all white needs to do at some point is
to just take off a pawn or even if you
want to maybe start pushing his own
pawns forward push this pawn forward or
you activate your own rook and okay wow
look at this king's journey magnus's
king is so deep inside black scamp that
wow
actually this is really nice he's
actually going to lock his own king in
my sim will be the winner and magnus
will be the winner in this match if he
wins this game and it's looking good
it's looking good and just as david
called it that pawn is coming forward to
just basically take control and
overwhelm black's defensive resources
and i have to say
this has just been genius stuff more
resistance i think no saving time mr
hikaru
moves his knight to another moose knight
he wishes uh he was a rook uh to an open
line
there we go magnus attacks a pawn brings
his rook to an open line
black's rook is forced to step back now
both of black's rook and king are just
totally passive almost powerless to move
yeah
so uh all
magnus needs to do is maximize his rick
and start pushing those pawns okay he's
done that there you go
yeah so black is forced to wait with his
rook
yeah i mean there's nothing more
difficult in chess than a position where
you just have to move back and forth and
back and forth and wait for the axe to
fight here comes breakthrough yeah it's
he's just opening a path for the white
rook also look at white's g-pawn the one
he used to lock down the position on
that right side that white g pawn is the
one that will become a new queen this
has conducted this end game i mean it's
just been instructive on so many levels
you know just this difference between a
bishop and a knight okay and now you see
the sixth rank has been opened where it
comes to give check and uh
white's rook white's rook take the pawn
and now the king is going to take
potentially if it wants magnus when he's
in this form okay so uh magnus taking us
capturing a pawn
black's last remaining hope is to create
a passport of his own
but uh black's lone pawn on the left
side is controlled by white's rook
and now magnus has it all worked out
yeah but i mean this is what we've kind
of been drumming in and in games you
know it's it has you have to work as a
team in the end game you know there's
it's not just one star it's everybody
ikaru
moving his rook to the bottom row and
this is a one once again a very neat
point from magnus his king steps to the
side and allows as david says for those
two pawns to march together and ten
seconds now for nakamura will he click
that resign button or will he play on
and show us the checkmate okay he's
playing on good
no he's not okay he makes a move it
seems but he resigns at the same time
magnus takes the win after another
really nice end game wow it's a dominant
match victory for magnus carlsen winning
two
games against hikaru nakamura